what's going on guys in this video i'm
going to explain the life of yamir fritz
who was the first character in attack on
titan to gain the power of the titans
yamir is the direct ancestor of those
with royal blood such as dinah fritz or
historia
but other aliens in the present day are
also her descendants which is why all
present day eldians
are referred to as subjects of ymir in
the mythology of attack on titan ymir is
believed by most people to have made a
deal with the devil
to inherit her titan powers but the
reality is totally different
this video will delve into how she
really acquired the power of the titans
as well as what her life was like before
she died and the full extent of her
titan abilities
i'll also briefly be touching on certain
events that happened after her death
although that is not the main focus of
this video before we get into it be sure
to sub for more attack on titan videos
like this
as we are on the road to 200k to begin
yamir was born in an unnamed village
around 2000 years before the start of
the series
during her childhood yami's village was
conquered by a tribe known as the
eldians
and at this time the king of the aldians
was a guy named fritz
the elden tribe was still relatively
small during his period so fritz would
grow his tribe by enslaving people from
the villages he conquered
and yamir became one of those slaves
after her village was destroyed
in her early life she didn't possess any
power of the titans or anything like
that
so she was powerless to fight back
against the oppression of the aldians
in season 3 of attack on titan frieda
rice described jamir
as someone who was kind and always
thinking of others yamir's kindness is
no doubt what led to her one day opening
the gate of the pigpen
and allowing one pig to escape in the
process i guess the other two pigs
didn't really feel like acquiring
freedom that day but whatever
when fritz heard that a pig was missing
all slaves were rounded up to determine
who was responsible
and if no one confessed to the crime
then every slave would have one of their
eyes taken out
understandably that threat did not get a
good reaction from the crowd
and all of the slaves immediately
pointed the finger at yamir
my theory is that the slave didn't know
for a fact that emil was responsible
but they blamed her because you know if
she's truly a kind person
then she'd be the most likely one to
think of doing something like this
after getting blamed king fritz declared
that ymir was now free to go
and she was sent into the woods as the
eldian soldiers hunted her for sport
they chased jamir on horseback as if she
was a wild animal
and their arrows pierced her in the leg
and the shoulder she probably thought
she was gonna die in this moment
but as she continued to stumble through
the forest ymir came across this
incredible looking tree with a gaping
entrance at the bottom
because she was looking for a place to
hide yamiya walked directly into the
entrance
but was taken by surprise because inside
the tree
was a hole that she subsequently fell
into isaiah
definitely tried to make this character
suffer as much as possible
that much i am certain of anyway inside
this hole was a pond
and yamil was submerged underwater as
she fell into it we can see from the air
bubbles that she was panicked by the
situation
but as she began to run out of air a
mysterious entity appeared out of
nowhere
and attached itself to yamir's spine in
the future
this entity would be referred to by erin
kruger as the source of all living
matter
although as i make this video there is
still no 100 confirmation
on what exactly it is after making
contact with this thing
ymir was instantly turned into the first
ever titan shifter
otherwise known as the founding titan
judging by the way she towered over
these trees
the original founding titan was even
bigger than bertolt's colossal titan
and its design was incredibly unique
unlike all the titans we've seen
the head of emir's titan is clearly just
a massive skull
her titan ribs are also permanently
sticking out which is a feature unique
to the founding titan
but as we saw from frida not every
finding titan has this feature
because of ymir's subservient
personality she didn't use the power of
the titans to get revenge on the eldian
tribe
but instead she remained as a slave for
king fritz
it's funny because fritz had genuinely
told yamir earlier that she was free to
go
but after she became a titan it seems
that she willingly went back to serve
him
this may seem like crazy behavior to us
but remember that ymir was still a young
girl
and had been conditioned to believe that
freedom was not an option
fritz then utilized her power to start
growing the aldian tribe
into the eldian empire as yumeus titan
would easily crush other nations in
battle
the country of mali was one of her
victims and honestly i can't blame them
because
what can you do against a monster like
this when all you have is it watched
spears and shields
you may would destroy aldia's enemies by
using the brute force of the founding
titan
but i think it's important to mention
that at this time she was not able to
use all the abilities of the founding
titan
that's because things like titan
creation and memory manipulation
only work when used on subjects of ymir
and at this time in history
there were no such subjects regular
human beings are
unaffected by the founding titan's other
abilities and so yamir wouldn't have
been able to turn people into titans or
do other cool stuff
that the future founding titans were
able to do after a few years of serving
the king she would of course go on to
have three daughters called maria rose
and sheena
if those names sound familiar to you
that's because the three wars on
parodies island
are named after yumiya's children these
daughters would then go on to become the
first subjects of ymir
but we'll talk about that later in the
video for now i should mention that in
the beginning
yamir's titan also built crucial
infrastructure such as roads and bridges
and it's my assumption that she would
have used the hardening like the
warhammer titan
to create these structures this helped
expand the aldean tribe
and allowed king fritz to recruit more
slaves who were subsequently made to do
manual labor
or serving the eldian army in a way you
could say that present day mali isn't
that different from the old aldian
empire
because i mean when we look at mali in
the present day they use titans to take
over other countries
and if you look at who serves in the
malian army most of the people
are either aliens or foreigners there
are very few malians in the malian army
anyway going back to ymir 13 years had
passed since she acquired the power of
the titans
and in that time the eldian empire had
grown incredibly wealthy
on the final day of her life a rogue
soldier in the ld military
attempted to assassinate king fritz but
being the person who always thinks about
other people
ymir jumped in front of the spear to
protect her husband and was killed as a
result
she must have been too severely injured
for her titan healing to kick in
as when we look at where the spear you
know where it pierced her it likely went
through her heart
an injury like that is probably too
severe for a titan shifter to heal from
and so yeah as a consequence she was
dead her daughters were obviously
horrified to see their mother die
but the king was even more shocked as
his invincible weapon had been killed
by what he described as a mere spear
fritz was desperate to not let the power
of the titans die out
and so he ordered his three daughters to
consume the body of their mother
in the hope that they themselves would
become titan shifters
after eating their mother the power of
ymir's founding titan was split between
the three children
and this division would continue until
there were nine titan shifters in total
according to malian propaganda the alden
empire would spread across the world
and would force other people to have
their children which of course would
mean there would be more subjects of
ymir
the fact is that the more subjects of
ymir there are the more pure titans
could be created
and the more pure titans there are then
the more countries lda could invade
it was just a vicious cycle of creating
titans taking over countries and then
doing the same thing all over again
upon her death all those years ago
yami's spirit woke up in a deserted
realm
where there was initially nothing but
sand however
once mario rose and sheena consumed the
spine of their mother
three parts were created in this world
that connected the three sisters
as they continued to have more
descendants who would then eat their
spines
the parts began to increase until it
became what it is today
each path represents a subject of ymir
who is capable of turning into a titan
or titan shifter
and what we found out in the manga was
that every titan that has ever existed
was personally created by ymir inside
this realm
whenever a titan shifter would transform
yamir herself would be in this realm
and would gather the necessary sand to
create that titan
in this image we can see how she created
the millions of colossus titans that
inhabit the walls of parodies island but
it's also stated that she made every
other titan shifter as well
you may be asking then who created
yamir's titans and i think i have an
answer for that
which is that we know that pars can
transcend time such as when aaron kruger
had memories of armin and mikasa
therefore if yamir is the one who makes
the titans then i guess in a
weird paradoxical way she likely also
made the founding titans that she used
herself
if you can send things into the past you
know whether it be memories
or the blood and bones of a titan then
yeah i don't see a reason why she didn't
make her own titan
but let me know what you think down
below perhaps was there another person
in this realm making titans before yamir
showed up
i'd love to know what you think down
below and of course hit that like button
if you like this video thanks for
watching and until the next one
peace out